[Music]
hey guys welcome to e3 2017 I'm Justin
here with Peter and we're checking out a
lot of really cool games and one of the
ones we just saw was battle chasers yeah
this kind of came out of nowhere for me
and it turned out to be a really
pleasant surprise the thing that drew it
to me was how artistically beautiful it
is the creative director behind it is a
gentleman who was also the creative
director on the dark Sider series with
vigil and he also has a background in
comics so it's got this really great
sort of you know comic art that pops and
there's a little bit of inspiration from
Darius a anime bit more like manga what
kind of gameplay does this have so this
is an RPG that uses dungeon crawling for
like what you'd imagine from like Diablo
but it has turn-based battles so when
you bump into enemies you actually get
into something that's closer to like
grandia's battle system but it's not
exactly that and actually even has some
influences from my favorite game full of
phaser tactics this was a Kickstarter
game that's now got a publisher in my
head a very successful Kickstarter
campaign as well yeah they wanted 500k
they got a close one eight hundred and
fifty K the game is now coming to switch
which is really cool well yeah so it's
on piston for Xbox one Windows switch
it's coming on October 3rd this is a
game to watch out for because I you know
it once you see it it's kind of like wow
this looks really interesting but then
once you really dive in there's a lot of
mechanics and they've really cherry
picked the best stuff from a slew of
RPGs well the Western and Eastern so
it's very surprising little game but you
know understanding the pedigree of who's
involved it's not that surprising once
you actually begin to wrap your head
around it and I'm surprised it's coming
out so soon yeah that's one we'll
definitely be looking forward to this
holiday season it sounds like 2017 is
gonna be really packed and to hear even
more about all these cool games that
we've saw at e3 2017 a check out
GameSpot calm
[Music]